Jordan is great to talk with you man
congratulations on an awesome game let's
go right to that last play where you
were at the 7 yard line and Weddell was
trying to strip you I mean how were you
able to fend him off and did you know
what he was trying to do and did you
know you'd be able to break that one oh
I forgot the ball up me I'll cut up
see ya bounce back out you knows me and
when I won and I went up to him and he
just tried to go for the ball so I put
two owners around it and I kept my legs
moving and he eventually fell off and
then I was able to get around the corner
because much I didn't had a good
blocking I was it was just where as far
as I could
yeah huge huge play put you guys down in
field goal range and then try Biscay had
that big throw to Kendall right to get
the field goal yeah that was one of the
crazier games Jordan that I've ever been
a part of did you feel that or noticed
that during the game with the kick
return touchdown where Rainey got hurt
the interceptions the punt return at the
I mean is that one of the crazier games
you've ever played in yeah definitely
very crazy again cuz the qatari I
thought he was down and then I can't
believe it took the permit arm back it
was a big player did it so 36 carries
man I mentioned obviously several of
those were in overtime but have you I
mean I know you played at UAB I you I
mean have you ever carried the ball that
many times in a college or NFL game
before oh you know but but not in the
NFL you got to tell me how you're
feeling how you feeling right now is I'm
I just felt pretty good I really saw my
resume owes those cares to like the last
you look do you know when you're in a
game do you know that you've gotten like
34 35 like did you know that while you
were playing I'm not really like in the
first half I thought I had like 40 that
like four or five I don't realize I had
it many what what do you think about too
risky and how he's done through the
first two games so far
he just had great boys eating over kids
righto oh we got it we got down hey
autumn oh nothing has got our ball
getting my stuff but you never let that
riding on me anything like that and then
stepped up and made a big play I hate it
you have you guys giving him a nickname
yet biscuit biscuit I love this don't
like it yeah I like it biscuit true
Biscay biscuit you guys can't where'd
you I mean obviously you came in with
his name is everybody calling him that a
lot of people call them that but that's
a nickname he's already had before he
got his appearances those kids are going
there's nothing you guys can come up
with to me to make fun of the fact that
he switched from Mitch to Mitchell you
guys couldn't go something out there
well you talked about his poise it's
impressive what about the poise of your
rookie running back tarik Cohen did you
see Jordan where he is the shortest guy
to throw a touchdown pass since we
Willie Smith in 1934 how big was this
win for you guys to get a win after what
happened Monday night and true Biscay
second star and on the road with
everything swirling around coach Fox and
the GM Ryan pace how big was it to get
that win played we always find a way to
lose the game ourselves they don't never
really beat us who didn't lose the game
ourselves and stuff like that like
Monday night oh yes many country so they
called resolutely game but it was just a
very big win it laughs our confidence
and those offers roll in like two years
well congratulations man that's a heck
of a day I mean you you you carried the
load and we're the biggest reason why
your team got the win with those 167
yards really appreciate the time
Thank You forever yep there he is Jordan
Howard the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience